hello guys Gregory albick here Tony Gill
right here so I was on Collider check
that wasn't on like their actual thing
bastards
they haven't invited me on you [ __ ]
Jesus I've met like all of you who
worked there what is it about me
um um anyway today there's a video that
drop called what Thor was doing during
civil war and I was like okay let me see
if people already requesting this sure
enough they are so I was like I'm gonna
shoot this right away I got my boy next
door who I saw Civil War with Tony is my
neighbor I get there early I'm just
selling time while this downloads it's
downloaded let's do this watch this [ __ ]
Thor was doing a bunch of nothing doing
so yeah I was just jacking off jae-joon
he is just watching we never had sex
Jane I've been wanting to have sex with
so Thor as some passionate kisses yeah
it I've never performed
I'm a virgin
all right great we have a bunch of shake
ago that was from happy anyway so I need
to me time and I came to Australia and
I'm in good with Gao I guess I just
wanted to be around average everyday
sort of everyday work that way while I'm
here I'm trying to get involved with the
Lotus who's this purple weirdo
electronic letter I write into Captain
America and Iron Man this used for
something very intense if there's any
other secrets you need just let me know
I'm not up to much I was working to you
he's working keep
delicious questions what all of the
information did and I like to call
visual clues speckle around the place
and who is the man whose birth the chair
magic lot doesn't like standing up I
really actually pronounced very song
verses in case got the right in the
Rainbow Bridge which a head it does if
you lift up distal thing what's he
holding I like you wait now can come up
no more how it's going
Carlos coming up you that's the possible
come on boy
hojun why Tony Stark in Captain America
Aiden can't thank you I'm a single [ __ ]
bone how many times do we have to go
amber this no amount of money is going
to get me to join your little pissing
contest
yeah talk to Thor yeah he's sort of been
waiting here from you oh yeah I just
wanted anybody to fight with him no
touch with you she doesn't have a phone
to fool me down just us Reggie oh my god
it's something else up the [ __ ] I was
awesome I whoa that was [ __ ]
hilarious that's the most funny thing
they've done that is so awesome man like
now uh it was just gonna be all Thor but
it was off
they gotta include where the Hulk was at
all time and why he wasn't acquitted
I don't anybody have this encompasses oh
man like I'm a huge fan of the office
and this is totally like that office
kind of humor well you got Thor in the
middle of the Ring and I think with
Chris Hemsworth you know despite what
the internet thinks of ghostbusters
I'll stand there and say that I thought
Chris Hemsworth was [ __ ] hysterical
in that film and he shows even more of
his comic charms that he brought with
the first store
I really felt you know like my favorite
funny moment in all the Marvel movies
was Thor drinking coffee
no that's slamming into he really does
show that he's got these like great
comedic dry delivery chops man oh god I
was looking like I'm rose hysterical I
just love how they didn't look like
their storyline to it was they just
didn't care really good there's no real
explanation like oh my god that Tony
Stark wanted Hulk and uh just both
didn't give him like even with the email
that he was sending one of the job like
a pacification email is just hilarious
to me I feel like if they did a 90
minute 80 to 90 minute film out of this
people would totally watch it well I
think it says like how they're trying to
do the Ben Kingsley a little like
spin-off yeah the one shot yeah the
Mandarin it's almost like they could
have done that with just Thor just
playing around for like a good 90
minutes if they were trying to jump into
it that is great this is like the
perfect addition to the muscle cinematic
uterus this feels like it was um [ __ ]
Deadpool like whoa Deadpool right right
I'm a lot of different things but like
it's funny cuz you noticed like Deadpool
would be doing that a lot more in his
movie so it was like when he did it was
like Otto's awesome so this one it feels
like a little treat like oh you haven't
seen Thor uh heard from Dora Thor in a
little bit this is [ __ ] here's what
he's been up to yeah just like it
definitely does to breaking the fourth
wall on the medic humor I was just so
good at like bringing it yeah howdy
that's what it's just nice man I like
especially how you
feels like the office it really does
like even when they have them talking
but when you have the office yeah dude I
like telling Jenna right now they're
riding on the wall yeah I did it like it
is right now Slayers got a gut he's like
leading a normal life and it's so Monday
oh my god that was looking really any
brilliant I want more of it yes wanna
keep doing this man like I liked all the
Deadpool little like sneak peeks we got
basically each commercial fell just a
little bit more creative and it felt
like Ryan Reynolds really like quit part
in the commercial not just like playing
it just for fun this one feels exactly
the same and since we haven't seen
really anything dad or it's a great way
to promote Thor the next core movie
because I know Thor the dark world is
considered by most to be like the least
likable one out of all the movie yeah so
this gets you like jacked up I didn't
see Thorin is on solo movie and
interacting with the Hulk it's it's a
great promo for the blu-ray release of
civil war explanation for worth what
Thor was doing and what Hulk was doing
on and to prep you for the next door
movie that's great that's fun that's
right so that's gonna actually be on the
blu-ray like I think this is a behind
the scenes okay see that's that's
interesting because you just get the
feel of like even though this is a civil
war movie and basically everybody from
the Avengers is just like yeah oh well
Thor wasn't it let's just throw them
away actually some some for them I mean
the blu-rays are always doing it right
man they'll do that with any other DVDs
now yes that was great I have a totally
why I hope they do more just like I'm up
gorgeous it's because it's Thor and
that's what make basic Gregg's God
hanging out with just normal dudes I
would say if they're not gonna put out
another Ragnar
Rocka like trailer yet like the first
one to come out then I would say just
keep bringing us more of this yeah
please like it blanks good if you grab
more Avengers that'd be great
all right well um yeah thanks guys for
wanting me to check this out this is a
smooth dough blight I'm gonna watch this
over over again if you're new to the
channel yes you can subscribe and Toni
uh what do we promote for Tony I was an
Instagram I'm just living my life you
know catch me on the street follow me
there you know the streets of Van Ness
oh that's how I pronounce it dirt you
stirred this dirty streets of vana dirty
like they don't come clean this [ __ ]
not like harm our apartments yes have
cockroaches yeah we live we have to go
on stomping spree
I hear ham bangin here's me me and it's
never sex never sailing cockroach it's
mostly like when you're like what's that
screaming is corny screaming is like no
she saw bugs and I smashed and I'm sorry
for wearing a flash shirt yeah I'm
mutual ma'am I'm Olga note that whoo